er selbst geht es nun endlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute wir haben
keine kosten gescheut das heißt ich und
hinter der kamera und habe eine drohne
angeschafft aber nicht irgendeine
sondern eine virtual reality drohen
damit diese brille funktioniert dem wir
werden heute ein rennen macht wer
jeweils dran es zieht sich diese brille
auf sieht dann durch die kameraden
natürlich die hier vorne was die drohne
sieht und muss die parkuhren möglichkeit
bestünde ist da hinten kommt doch mehr
komfort und zwar heute die drohne stadt
genau hier dann wird das mussten
jeweilige einmal die sonne wie
rumfliegen die jagd auf zwei und
hierdurch für das arbeitszimmer des tc
ach so dann ist okay wenn ihr ein stück
gekriegt haben ja das war alles klar die
rein fliegen da wieder umdrehen paar
wird auf und dann hier auf diesem
wunderschönen helikopterlandeplatz land
aber die ganze sache ist nicht umsonst
tätig bin da auf den inseln von den
verlierer übernehmen holland und eine
story heraus war vollkommen falsch zu
machen was er denkt an seinen afrika was
jeweils aussuchen und der andere das
licht löschen das muss online 24 stunden
min jetzt wirds wenn du da seien sie
doch so nett und stellen sich den
zuschauern des heutigen rennens vor wer
sind sie und wie lange ist ihre mein
name ist lukas reimann ich hab ja schon
ein treffen an schweren jahren aber wie
schätzen sie ihre chancen gegen den
langjährigen titelverteidiger sc in der
langjährige teamverteidiger wer sind sie
und was machen die so können sie mal
ganz kurz vorstellen bitte also
danke reicht dann auch also mein name
ist und ich bin heute hier um gegen den
reimann anzutreten der herr reimer ist
ja schon sehr gut muss man sagen im
racing das habe ich jetzt anders gehört
ja also ich hab gehört der herr einmal
hatte und längst auch eine weisheitszahn
op ich glaube das ist so gar nicht
einfach sehr eingeschränkt und dann ist
heute einfach nicht in der körperlichen
verfassung hin gegen mich anzutreten ich
habe auch die zähne bei dem die weiße
zähne reingemacht wir daraus machen
lassen muss und dann angeblich schwächer
ist sie waren das
[Musik]
ich habe es jetzt auch ich sehe nur noch
das bild von der mode
da legen wir los gemischt das ist ja das
würde ich von der decke bis heute
jetzt ist wieder die treppe hoch jetzt
also bis zu stören
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist bloß mit mir suchen jetzt nicht
richtig spannend wird es einmal
geschaffen das eine kunden-hotline
entstehen der guckt einfach nicht ich
hab jetzt hatte ich ein bisschen vor der
gruppe der
[Musik]
die sättel ist drin einmal auf dem
teppich hier einer die luft dann wieder
raus gar kein ding du musst einmal in
richtung mich mir fliegt nicht mit dem
schwert haben jetzt müssen wir noch auf
diese helikopter landeplatz auf diesen
tag haben wir selbst schaffen jetzt auch
diesem handicap dass das sind derzeit
schaffen wieder abgefallen ist da noch
nichts gewonnen
alter modul ist mein kopf der deko die
haben gerade eben das gerne verfolgt was
sagen sie zur performance ihres
kontrahenten komplett geschäft ja ich
denke ich habe eine super performance
hingelegt es wird auf jeden fall reichen
denn herr einzuschlagen da haben glaube
ich nicht kannst du das daran liegt dass
sie bereit sind wenn sie nicht herr
reimann tag ist immer an einer hand
sechs finger
was wissen sie dann damit
denken sie daran und kann ich dann alles
noch gefährlich werden mit seiner
leistung gleich auf gar keinen fall am
[Musik]
unser volk ist auch egal sind dabei
immer wieder so aussieht
märz ruft an das geht nicht
schau mal in dieser zeit auf die ganze
partie ist es nicht wenn es den erfolg
sagen ja das heißt sie wissen nein nein
der deutsche der in zwei stunden muss
einfach genau jetzt muss aller welt app
ist
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wie gesagt okay ich mache und ich will
dich raus hatte ich stelle mich auf
einen stuhl unglaublich wohl auch den
befehl zum stocken die koffer packen
müssen wir gas geben
[Musik]
folgerichtig auch das ist doch nicht das
ist so fucking schwierig nun mit der
rivalität you can't we can ja darin soll
ich hier
[Musik]
alles klar dann habe ich die challenge
gewonnen
luther war wirklich alles klar ja und
ich das werde ich machen
nein das gibt es nicht daher wie man sie
heute als absoluter underdog ins rennen
gestartet haben es dann tatsächlich für
sich entscheiden können ja was sagen sie
dazu
alles in kauf genommen unten handy
kennen sie auch in kauf genommen habe
ich in kauf genommen also ins gekauft
ich hab's gekauft und ich habe halt
gewonnen und ich muss wirklich sagen es
war ein spannendes match pacers war eine
einseitige nummer heute
ich finde werden alles klar wir leider
leichte tonstudio hier ist tut uns
wirklich leid also ich es war
man kann natürlich jetzt den er an es
kann auch nicht mit anderen gegnern
vergleichen in dieser liga jetzt schon
besser als die meisten er schon schlecht
hat sie mal sagen sie noch mal was
als keiner ja also das ist das toll
machen muss mein handy
nein ich glaube ich habe mein handy
verloren das machen wir jetzt wenn ich
mein handy verloren habe
nehmen sie das alles ist super hier ist
das handy inzwischen hoffen weiß was
machen ist ja was geht meine damen und
herren hier ist die laser tracker mir
gern erfolgen haben 17 10 kommen eine
pizza aus am ersten zwölf beim
merchandising und irgendwann haben wir
noch ein neues buch schreibe ich gerade
also texas aus kein problem
praktisch so wurde den zeitraum ja ich
glaube das ist die optimale menge alles
klar leute das was von diesem video hier
drüben könne mainka abonnieren und hier
bekommt ihr persönlich vorgestellt das
bio
wenn er traurig seid dann lacht